[Musique]
oui
et aux doucement doucement le coach
aux
dépens du lait tout chaud
ces quatre éleveurs ont tous hérité une
ferme familiale dans le loir et cher
mais ils ont choisi leur propre modèle
d'élevage
un élevage à taille humaine respectueux
de l'environnement ces jeunes
agriculteurs n'ont rien inventé il
l'élève juste leurs animaux selon leur
éthique et leurs convictions
la vallée de l'a6 au nord de blois dans
la petite bosse une zone humide où les
bleus island s'épanouissent au côté de
victor et son père à la ferme des petits
très fier c'est une lumière nouvelle un
bruce
m'installer en élevage mais je
m'installe dans pas n'importe quel
élevage déjà c'est l'élevage familial et
en plus c'est un un modèle d'élevage qui
qui
qui nous correspond et qui me
corresponde à moi aussi j'aurais du mal
à m'installer en élevage
autre qu'un ici qu
on s'est adapté au milieu en fait voilà
on n'a pas n'a pas contraint le milieu
on sait on a cherché l'espèce qui
pouvaient qui pouvait convenir à ces
milieux là et puis et puis voilà qui est
puis ça se passe très bien par contre ce
sont des espèces pour lequel il faut il
faut du temps voilà c'est des espèces à
croissance lente donc pour pâques
pressés
pour avoir un morceau dans son assiette
il faut presque cinq ans
après un bac agricole et un bts gestion
victor a aussi passé un c ap boucherie
et a travaillé trois ans comme boucher
depuis qu'il est installé une fois par
mois le jeune éleveur des coûts et
composent les colis de viande avec un
boucher retraité dans le laboratoire de
la ferme
tout ce que tu prend
[Musique]
3,3 baguette que les enlèvent ou
trop premier oui
tout cela partir de là à abane on est à
la base on est éleveur
même si j'ai appris de façon à voir
quelqu'un d'expérience avec nous c'est
c'est toujours toujours toujours un
verbe est indispensable
ici l'avion des mâtures et trois
semaines avant d'être découpés les
coliques sont vendus uniquement sur
comment tu as well as les deux cuisses
et les deux aloyau
c'est considérer comme les meilleurs
morceaux ce qui est à l' est là
pour autant pour autant nous on n'élève
pas les animaux que pour ces deux
morceaux là c'est aussi là où il ya le
plus de demandes mais
notre façon de travailler aux siennes
nous permet de
valoriser tous les morceaux d'un bout à
l'autre de la viande de la tête avec
comme victor de plus en plus d'éleveurs
souhaite découper la viande de leurs
animaux et la vendre en direct
[Musique]
tout maîtriser de l'élevage à la
distribution c'est aussi l'objectif de
baptiste en sologne il vient de
rejoindre l'exploitation familiale avec
ses idées on allait dans le labo de
transformation donc on a monté la
près de la tour
cet ajout a mis en service
baptiste a travaillé pendant cinq ans en
boucherie avant son installation à la
ferme pour lui la découpe était une
compétence indispensable acquérir
j'aime ça comme ça c'est aussi ou mais
où les animaux parte je sais enfin voila
je sais qu'ils seront respectés je vais
respecter celle mg respect quand je les
découpe ja respect quand je les vends
enfin voilà ça c'est quelque chose qui
me tenait à coeur et puis en plus ça
permettait aussi en fin d'année de la
nouveauté sur la ferme
l'application
est la plus grande nouveauté que
baptiste a apporté à la ferme familiale
la voici un élevage de cochons au pays
des sangliers chaque année il achète 60
porcelets les engraisse et les ventes en
direct deux fois par semaine la vocation
la mer
ça me plait ne vois pas faire autre
chose et ouais c'est une fin
c'est une fierté de bien nourrir les
gens tués le beurre mais je suis plus
l'éleveur de dans le temps où
l'on repasse notre vie sur la ferme
voilà j'ai écouté
je fais ce qui me plaît je suis heureux
je me lève le matin je suis content je
rentre le soir je suis content
voilà
à l'origine la ferme familiale ne
comptait que des vaches limousines le
père de baptiste est aidant des premiers
éleveurs bio de sologne quand son fils
s'est lancé faute de terrains
supplémentaires disponibles dans le coin
il a réduit son cheptel bovin pour
laisser de la place aux cochons de
baptiste il s'installait avec moi mais
il a mené son projet quoi de a à z donc
il a fait vraiment son installation
n'est pas arrivé dans la ferme avait
quelque chose qui était tout près tout
fait don aux sirènes à tous tout ce qui
est communication je pense qu'ils sont
très forts aussi israël et qu'ils ont
donc créé une page facebook qu'ils ont
fait une campagne participative
c'est motivant quand on voit que les
gens qui suivent donc est quand même on
voit qu'avec des gens derrière qui sont
prêts à investir et à soutenir et et
surtout j'espère acheter des produits
la plus grande difficulté que ces jeunes
éleveurs rencontre en sologne et le
foncier
avec la multiplication des terrains de
chasse privées les terres agricoles
disparaissent peu à peu
[Musique]
nice a repris la ferme familiale laissé
à l'abandon il ya cinq ans beria il a
rapidement été confrontés au manque de
terres disponibles
il n'a pas pu agrandir son troupeau
malgré la demande en agneau qui augmente
chaque année
bon secteur là on est presque à 15000
euros l'hectare donc pour un jeune
agriculteur qui va s'installer c'est
compliqué surtout que voilà c'est pas on
est en sologne ce ne sont pas des terres
qui rapporte hausse en ce sens originel
c'est à dire que voilà on fait pousser
un peu d'air mais c'est très compliqué
ici de faire des cultures l'élevage
valorise très très bien les terres
pauvres de sologne mais malgré ça on a
beaucoup de mal aujourd'hui à trouver
des perles et hausse on travaille plus à
c'est fini et hausse vient là
il est devenu éleveur à 30 ans
journaliste et documentariste à new york
il est revenu dans cette ferme où il a
grandi il lui a plu un peu redonné
son grand-père était encore de ce monde
quand ils les brebis sont revenus ici en
2017 je pense qu'il ne croyait pas moins
quand il me voyait faire les travaux
quand ils me voyaient me réinstaller
progressivement ils pensaient que
c'était une lubie d'un temps que ça
passerait que c'était juste quelque
chose comme ça et puis un jour il a vu
l'habitat y arriver il a vu les brebis
descendre il a eu un peu les larmes aux
yeux en se disant vinci rigolait pas
qu'il est fou il rigolait pas en plus et
je pense que ce petit côté de fierté
aussi en me disant que mon grand père a
connu ça et avant deux avant de quitter
cette ferme dans laquelle il a passé
toute sa vie il l'a vu revivre un petit
peu
pour faire vivre la ferme les brebis ne
suffisait pas nils a dû diversifier ses
activités
il a choisi l'apiculture la ferme saint
marc compte 400 ruches près de la moitié
est réservé à l'élevage
ont fait à la fois la production de miel
de pollen de propolis mais on fait aussi
de la vente des saints et de la vente de
règne tout ça c'est des reines
sélectionné doukanane partie qu'on va
garder pour nous pour l'année prochaine
et une partie qu'on va vendre à les
apiculteurs amateurs et professionnels
pour leur cheptel
je me sens éleveurs d'abeilles j'essaie
de les abeilles se sont le mieux
possible dans des environnements qui
leur vont bien et si si les conditions
météo le son bien si les abeilles sont
bien élevés si on a une année qu'il
permet on arrive à faire du miel et on
va on va prélever le surplus du miel
voilà c'est vraiment ça moi mon métier
c'est d'élever les abeilles si ça va
bien elles font du miel mais ça c'est
pas moi qui décide
[Musique]
l'humilité face à la nature c'est aussi
ce qu'a à brias d'elle lorsqu'elle a
repris l'exploitation de ses parents
dans le perche après avoir passé dix ans
à paris comme secrétaire de direction
à dell a choisi de revenir dans cette
ferme où elle est née elle souhaitait
travailler en extérieur et surtout
redonner du goût aux aliments en élevant
les volailles comme la géline de
touraine je voulais un peu me battre
pour la sauvegarde du patrimoine
culinaire qu'on en région centre on a la
chance d'avoir plusieurs races locales
dont la géline de touraine et la force
d'appoint ou non j'avais envie de
travailler sur les races qui était en
disparition est d'essayer de si on peut
sauvegarder un tout petit peu de notre
richesse qu'on patrimoine pas autant
qu'on le fasse
comme cette jeune éleveuse ne fait rien
à moitié elle a quasiment atteint
l'autonomie alimentaire pour ses animaux
grâce aux céréales déjà cultivées à la
ferme par ses parents des céréales
aujourd'hui totalement bio nous ont
produit déjà ici à la ferme le blé le
triticale les féveroles où les poisses
et des protéagineux dont ils ont besoin
d'un apport protéagineux et on achète en
fait du tourteau de soja français bio
voilà comme ça ça donne un petit coup de
pouce à nos collègues du coin
[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas prêt à sortir aller de
l'autre côté
voilà dans sa nouvelle vie d'éleveur
adèle n'est pas seul maman de trois
enfants elle est soutenue par ses
parents retraités mais très actif à la
ferme ça c'est mon papa il vient
regarder le mur fils
c'est bon c'est mon sage savez la
personne à qui on joue toujours les
trucs pour sait jamais je vais remonter
j'ai mis un 27
pour les céréales et les poussins c'est
son papa qui la conseillent à tour
rejoint
pour la préparation des colis et la
vente directe c'est avec sa maman
qu'elle fait équipe une maman qui était
plutôt inquiète quand sa fille est
revenue travailler à la ferme au départ
je n'étais pas pour du tout du tout du
tout peuvent que bon on avait tellement
bavé nous que voulait pas que notre
fille ait la même vie et en veine que
mentale elle fait autrement que nous
donc c'est pas si génial je sais ce que
je produis mais je sais ce que je vends
donc comme j'essaye de faire un maximum
de choses par moi-même je maîtrise la
situation
maintenant moi ma vocation c'est pas de
nourrir la planète entière c'est pas
possible pour moi je suis pas du tout
fait pour ça moi c'est de vivre de mon
métier d'être une petite unité est
d'avoir un marché de niche avec voilà
des amapiens des restaurateurs et voilà
mais à mon avis on agriculture là
beaucoup de place pour beaucoup moins
dix ans après son changement de vie
adele ne regrette rien elle a même
l'impression d'appartenir à une sorte d'
équipes de jeunes éleveurs qui partagent
la même philosophie pense qu'on n'écoute
passionnés et qu'on le fait pas pour
l'argent ça c est qu on le fait
peut-être plus pour la qualité de vie et
et faire des choses pour soi
être peut-être s'accomplir différemment
[Musique]
abel victor nils et baptiste ont choisi
un modèle d'élevage qui leur ressemble
autonome respectueux de la nature et du
bien-être animal
ces jeunes éleveurs ne rejette pas les
autres modèles ils ont juste construit
celui qui leur correspondait le mieux